well that was a little bit anticlimactic
hook us up and brothers big dramatic
welcome home video and nobody's here so
I'm going to see where they are
just arrived back in Toronto I was in
first class had 18 the first off the
plane don't have any badges carry on I'm
excited to be home I haven't slept much
at all and we're going to see if we can
find Nina
I
throw it on facebook so let's see should
ether team I am here
she wrote at four-thirty he's 13 I don't
know what that means I parked okay wait
walking oh she's walking okay well let's
wait
there she is there's the Nina what
happened I'm sweaty know about you
you're late I'm not late it was yeah was
the traffic
i miss that me
there you go see look look who it is
look who's [ __ ] okay well i was telling
them that I had hoped for some big you
know I walk out at the door and then
oh he's here nobody's here to be here
it's perfect and I let you let Grady
1142 for so long ago where happened
nobody's here but now our life is here
so that's it and I love you so do
something special for the ones that you
love today that's the message and
believe okay
okay let me turn this off ah bear hug oh
yeah she's little but she's very strong
so don't mess with her oh let's see that
again right okay okay hi